Red carpets, private jets, exotic locations
— the life of an actor may seem pretty plush.
But don't forget that being an actor requires
work, and it often means running into some
pretty uncomfortable situations.
When things go too far and a star declines
to do a scene, fans can't help but speculate
as to what kind of drama went down on set.
Here's a look at some movie scenes that actors
refused to film.
Body double
Isla Fisher's breakthrough role as "stage-5
clinger" Gloria Cleary in 2005's Wedding Crashers
catapulted her to fame — and earned her
a reputation as a comedic force.
The film was a huge hit at the box office,
thanks in part to raunchy R-rated gags.
But as far as Fisher was concerned, unclothed
scenes were an absolute dealbreaker.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
she elaborated on just how many scenes she
skipped…and how many stand-ins her shooting
contract stipulated.
She said:
"I had a hand double for the under-the-table
scene.
I had a breast double for the boob-in-the-face
and I had a butt double.
My argument was, if you see a character's
breast, she's no longer funny.
I lost that argument with the producers."
Too Furious
The Fast and the Furious franchise is a juggernaut,
but production on the eighth installment,
The Fate of The Furious, was less than full-speed
ahead thanks to the competing egos of two
of the franchise's biggest stars — Dwayne
Johnson and Vin Diesel.
In fact, it was ultimately revealed that the
beef was so bad, the two totally refused to
film together.
It all started in 2016, when Johnson went
on a social media rant during filming.
In a since deleted Instagram post, he wrote
in part:
"Some [men] conduct themselves as stand up
men and true professionals, while others don't.
The ones that don't are too chicken s— to
do anything about it anyway."
TMZ reported that the day after, Johnson and
Diesel had a hush-hush meeting — which pretty
much confirmed that Diesel was the subject
of Johnson's social media vent session.
Sources reported that things were so uncomfortable
on set that it was "impossible to shoot scenes."
In a 2018 interview with Rolling Stone, Johnson
himself confirmed that they didn't film any
scenes together, and his scenes with Diesel
in The Fate of The Furious were the product
of clever post-production work
"It ain't too late to stop this."
The end for Emma
Emma Watson has demonstrated serious range
in a variety of roles since breaking through
as a child actor in Harry Potter… but none
of it prepared her for her uncomfortable cameo
in This Is the End.
The dark comedy was pretty much exactly what
you'd expect from Seth Rogen and his writing
partner Evan Goldberg, whose over-the-top
sensibilities were established with Superbad.
"Here let me see it."
"It's real, it's heavy."
"Ahhh!
Come on, guys!"
"Bang bang!"
Like the rest of the all-star cast, Watson
played an exaggerated version of herself — but
she didn't exactly feel welcome in the boys'
club atmosphere during filming.
According to an extra, Watson walked off the
set over a scene featuring Channing Tatum
in a surprise cameo, doing the full-on Magic
Mike.
"Channing introduce yourself."
"What's up, guys.
You cool?"
"It's Channing Tatum!"
"What the f---!"
PopFocal picked up the since-deleted blog
post, which alleged,
"Channing decided to do some of his breakdancing
in front of her but alas he was in nothing
but a thong…
Emma storms off set…
So we wrapped the night 5 minutes later."
James Franco seemed to confirm the story in
conversation with Interview magazine.
He explained:
"So a funny thing happened on this movie I'm
doing.
The movie is a comedy, but it's kind of an
outrageous one, and this actress — I won't
say who, but she had a smaller role in the
film — walked off the movie in the middle
of a scene."
Watson has never commented on her alleged
exit, although she later indicated that she
enjoyed her time on the film.
"How could I miss out on the chance to work
with some of the best, the most impressive
lineup of the best comedians in the world
right now."
Absentee Blade
The Blade trilogy was Marvel's first three-quel,
but the final installment, Blade: Trinity,
didn't exactly wow audiences when it premiered
in 2004.
Panned by critics as being shallow and scattered,
it left fans disappointed — especially after
Snipes filed a lawsuit against the production
company after the film's release.
Eight years after the film came out, cast
member Patton Oswalt shed some light on what
went down — namely that Snipes allegedly
refused to film most of his scenes.
Oswalt told the A.V.
Club,
"He wouldn't come out of his trailer […] he
only [came to the set] for close-ups.
Everything else was done by his stand-in.
I only did one scene with him."
Oswalt also revealed that Snipes had big beef
with writer-director David Goyer, stemming
from an argument during a night out in Vancouver
while filming.
As the feud continued, things only got more
ridiculous.
"After a while he resorted to giving people,
communicating with post-its.
He would give one to the director, each one
he would sign 'Blade.'"
Off Pitch
Anna Kendrick found international superstardom
in Pitch Perfect as Beca, The Bellas' rebellious
soprano — and it sounds like her real-life
personality isn't far from the tough-talking
undergrad she played on the big screen.
Kendrick spoke out about putting her foot
down on a potential storyline that had Beca
getting romantically involved with a record
executive who was trying to get the Bellas'
master of the mash-up to sign with his label.
She told Harper's Bazaar UK:
"Originally the music executive was supposed
to be my romantic interest but I said no to
that, because I thought that would be kind
of f—ing problematic."
In the same interview, Kendrick revealed that
she pushed back on producers who asked the
Bellas to step into more revealing wardrobes,
saying:
"It's funny.
Whenever we do the wardrobe fittings I feel
like we get notes from the top saying they
should be tighter [...] and show more skin.
And I'm like, that's not why people are coming
to see the movie."
Kissing pains
Kirk Cameron's strict Christian faith means
that he considers even the smallest onscreen
romantic gesture to be risqué — which is
why he told producers of the 2008 faith-based
family drama Fireproof that he wouldn't be
kissing his co-star.
As Cameron claimed during an appearance on
the Today Show, it wasn't just the kiss — he
clashed with producers over several storylines
he felt were immoral, mainly that his firefighter
character spends much of the film contemplating
divorce.
That commitment to marriage meant that Cameron
refused to film the big kiss scene the way
it was written.
So the film crew changed up the scene, utilizing
low lighting and tight angles to put Cameron's
own wife in the shot, dressed up in the female
lead's costume.
Awww.
And they say romance is dead.